President Biden causing major confusion
after a federal judge pulled the plug on
his mask mandate for planes and trains
Biden sounding like he wouldn't put up a
fight over the ruling
Mr President should people continue to
wear masks on planes that's up to them
but then just hours later his doj said
it will be appealing the decision if the
CDC says it's necessary to keep it in
place and cue the White House to mop up
Biden's mess
the president was answering the question
quite literally which means right now as
you know we are not implementing The
Mask mandate because of the court order
which we disagree with to be clear we
are recommending everyone wear masks on
planes that is what the CDC is
recommending that is the public health
guidance We are following
meanwhile the Liberals are absolutely
losing their minds
New York Times columnist Powell Krugman
acting like a total crybaby he's
predicting violence and harassment
toward mask wearers after the Mandate
was lifted and others are lashing out at
the brave judge who struck down the rule
perhaps that's the mark of an
inexperienced judge I don't think this
ruling makes a lot of legal sense did
announcing the end of the Mask mandate
literally in the middle of the flight
kind of let those a-holes win this
decision is going to single-handedly
accelerate cases throughout the U.S it's
not only not the right time it's a
little early but it's not even the right
manner in which these mayonnaise were
overturned this is a legal ruling it is
not a scientific ruling
amazing Dana I'll start with you it's a
legal and not a scientific ruling and
yet it is a legal ruling based upon the
law that jensaki says we're still
following the CDC what's going on well
okay so
one to be perfectly clear it's like the
left believes that the court mandated
people not wear a mask
that's not what happened
you have as the president said it is
your personal choice and when this if
they do appeal this and they get to make
arguments if I was the The Entity that
brought the case in the first place
saying that this mandate oversteps its
Authority all I would do is play the
sound bite from President Biden in which
he said
it's up to you it's a personal choice
the defense rests okay because that's
what the court is not saying you can't
you have it that you are not allowed to
wear a mask you are if you want to the
other thing is the way that our system
works at the justice department is
there's a Office of the solicitor
general that is the entity that decides
upon appeals and that's why you see them
think gosh okay well what are we going
to do here the seat the judge says that
the CDC overstepped its boundaries
there's not a law that says that the CDC
was allowed to do this the CDC went too
far if the Congress wants to pass a law
and the President Biden wants to sign it
they are perfectly in their rights to
try to do that so that they could move
forward the other thing that they're
concerned about is that let's say that
the CDC says you should everyone needs
to wear a mask through the end of 2022
and the solicitor general takes that to
court and they lose
now you've set a precedent that the CDC
doesn't have even that Authority that
they had from the past two years so
they're a little bit in between a rock
and a hard place the president is
constantly caught up in this thing where
he knows what the answer is the answer
is it's up to you that's what he said
but then they try to back into it and
say well actually because the left is
really mad so now sure we have to do
this we're going to ask the solicitor
general is going to defer to the CDC
about an appeal that to me is completely
backwards agree you know Geraldo you're
an attorney look the judge made it very
clear the CDC
um went beyond its Authority Congress
did not give the CDC the authority to
make this rule it didn't give it the
authority without at least some
additional steps that were not taken so
why are they saying we have to listen to
the CDC and if they decide to appeal
apparently they're thinking about it
waiting on the CDC which is the dumbest
thing I ever heard the CDC is the reason
you lost the case but aside from that if
they decide to appeal feel if they look
at those numbers right now CDC and
scientists have to say this is not a
time where we can mandate a mask we're
not in an emergency this is a missed
opportunity this is a lot like uh the
recent Supreme Court nominees
confirmation hearings the last two
there's a chance where people could be
gracious where people could just go with
the flow the president said it is up to
us on the masks uh the genie is out of
the bottle you can't put it back in
people will not I'm going to the airport
as soon as we finish broadcasting this
live show so should I wear a mask you're
supposed to wear a mask in the terminal
now because that's a New York city
ordinance they want to get on the plane
where there's much bigger crowd and you
know the much more chance of
transmission there are no masks mandated
so it's there is illogic now Biden in my
opinion missed an opportunity to be that
guy that gracious guy and to say even
though I I disagree with this judge even
if this judge was an experience even if
this judge exceeded her Authority down
floor even this was a political decision
none of that matters Americans were sick
of The Masks The Masks have served their
function maybe it's true I heard Claire
or mccaskill say millions of people's
lives were saved by the mass I doubt
that maybe maybe thousands were maybe
hundreds were I don't know I'm not a
scientist but I do know that now the
time of the masks have passed and it's
time for America to move on and it's
amazing Joey that that jensaki says you
know we're going to follow the science
and you know we think you should keep
wearing the mask well the amazing thing
is you could take the mask off for the
president's State of the Union you know
a little hypocrisy and the Gridiron
though I'm I'm not a scientist either
but I did fly today so I have spent a
lot of time on an airplane there are two
things that stake here none of them have
anything to do with science the first is
the government's fight to keep
government's control over anything so I
inspect the body Administration to push
in defense of the cdc's ability to tell
us what we can do but not over
coronavirus the other thing is Joy Reid
was completely honest he's like don't
let the other team win don't let the
a-holes Win It has nothing to do with
science or health or the fact that
immunocompromised people have to worry
about pretty much every airborne disease
they could catch not just coronavirus it
has everything to do with for the last
two years we've been in this dog fight
and don't let them win and that's all
that's all it is for them and at least
Joy Reid was honest about it and you
know Greg I mean Paul Krugman saying
that he's that now we can expect
violence towards those who are The Mask
wearers and the amazing part of that is
that this is the same Krugman who
predicted that the stock market would
crash and never recover if Donald Trump
were elected president this guy won a
Nobel Beast a Nobel uh a prize Well I'm
afraid that he's right last night I had
gone out to get something to eat and uh
in my mask
and two guys in Red Hats
white men in Trump hats had took my mask
and told me this was maggot country so I
do think I think I think Krugman has
signaled a new era I kind of mentioned
this before they don't know what they're
doing but they're creating a new
identity class which is the masks and
they're also going to be the victim
class that is what krugman's talking
about make way for them being penalized
and marginalized and smeared and perhaps
attacked generally in identity politics
you have people of color you have women
non-binary disabled but now he's
anointed masks as identity markers like
a hijab or hijab not sure what I kept I
apologize if I got it wrong but if you
know what you mean but if the masks are
indeed uh the victims of those in power
then uh you know it's kind of
interesting because it is like
when Islamic countries criminalized not
wearing coverings meaning that if you
didn't wear a burqa you would be beaten
or arrested
the left the left this in America
defended the right for women to wear the
burqa when that wasn't the problem no
one was saying don't wear it they were
saying wear it so what you're seeing
right now is you're actually saying my
God if these are people telling you not
to wear a mask when it's your right to
wear a mask this is just like that when
in fact no no no no no no it's not you
are creating you're creating an identity
class that's now going to be part of a
component of this and now does that mean
that we're going to have hate crimes
legislation for the mass if I choose to
wear a mask will I be appropriating use
the mask wearer it will Elizabeth Warren
claimed that she's 50 mask the next time
she runs for office but we segregate the
math from the unmasked will it be
affirmative action we the leftism works
this way identify a group identify them
as victims Target the oppressor but they
don't even I don't think he sees that
he's doing it it's insane but when
everybody is forced to wear a mask
you're not single dad out as someone who
believes in the mass religion and Biden
ran on I'm going to return everyone to
normal and like for six months from the
midterms and he's still like um
it's Insanity hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else